fox news alert president biden taking
questions from reporters a short time
ago but again from a list of
predetermined reporters notably only
three this time
it was the questions were on the
multitude of problems the administration
is facing right now multiple crises
including the crisis at our southern
border thousands of mostly haitian
migrants have been camped out under a
del brio del uh del rio bridge in texas
the images have been shocking to say the
least but video of border patrol agents
chasing migrants on horseback have
sparked the most outcry president biden
himself has remained silent about the
situation until today but instead of
owning what's been happening under his
watch the president threw border patrol
under the bus
do you take responsibility for the chaos
that's unfolding of course i take
responsibility i'm president but i was
horrible with the city as you saw to see
people treat it like they did horses
barely running over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences
there will be consequences it's an
embarrassment but beyond an
embarrassment it's dangerous it's wrong
it sends the wrong message around the
world
president biden also dodged an important
question from our own peter ducey
[Music]
[Applause]
amazing always dodging those questions
uh look bill malugen harris has reported
just before we came to air that the
photographer who took that picture the
infamous picture of the mounted border
patrol agents in del rio says he and his
colleagues never saw agents whipping
anyone and the photos are being
misconstrued not only by president biden
who is lying about this moments ago his
own vice president doubled down on the
lie let's roll the tape
first of all i've been very clear about
the images that you and i both saw of
those law enforcement officials on
horses i i i was outraged by it
i it was horrible and um and
deeply troubling
there's been now an investigation that
is being conducted which i fully support
and there needs to be consequence and
accountability uh the human beings
should not be treated that way and as we
all know it also evoked images
of some of the worst moments of our
history
where that kind of behavior has been
used against
the indigenous people of our country has
been used against african americans
during times of slavery
laughing well
i don't understand it must be like a
reflexive tick well look
um
just to go back to the president for a
second
the evidence does not show the physical
evidence does not show the photographer
has come forward does not show what
president biden and vice president
kamala harris are saying happened it was
sop standard operating procedure to put
law enforcement and border patrol on
horses you've heard that from both sides
of the aisle and i don't know if you
caught it from leslie marshall
just previously
a democrat on my show she went into
quite detail about this
about how that is how they handle and
law enforcement all over the country in
different situations handle it that way
so when the president says consequences
he is the judge jury he's not even
willing to believe any other scenario
happened other than the fantasy or
narrative that he has in his head so far
now if evidence comes forth that
something untoward happened i'm sure
somebody will rush to it but right now
the only thing they're rushing to is to
judgment and that is harmful because the
very same people that you have called on
to keep us safe over the last few months
when policies were driving our our
safety into the ground at that border
are doing their job night and day right
now and and a healthy thank you would be
wonderful and by the way why didn't
secretary of the dhs majorca say
anything when he saw those same men and
women on horseback
this week when he went to the border i'm
all shades of confused about how now
kamala harris and the president of the
united states want to point to a
situation where the facts don't bear
this out
now
is it a terrible image well clearly
people are upset about it so when the
president says consequences i hope he
starts with himself because those images
came out of a situation that he created
so if you want to put everybody on the
ground you're going to need more people
on the ground which they've been saying
no matter what their transportation mode
is you need more people at the border
let's see if the president can rectify
what has been broken under his
administration for the last eight and a
half months not yet absolutely and you
have william lodgeness fox's reporter
saying hey they've been using horses for
117 years his reporting showed border
patrol feels that they've been
scapegoated they can't speak on the
record they can't defend themselves so
instead they're being thrown under the
bus and they say twirling is a technique
used often it's to keep someone else an
illegal migrant from grabbing the
harness it could be a dangerous
situation but hey don't don't listen to
the facts listen to maxine waters and
her vicious lies
what the hell are we doing here
what we witness
takes us back hundreds of years
what we witnessed was worse than what we
witnessed in slavery
emily
i mean i can't speak to maxine waters
emotional reaction to that but what i
can speak to is the fact so i'm happy to
educate her along with the president and
vice president who don't seem to know
facts so what you alluded to our mounted
guard
patrolled the border on horseback
beginning in 1904 in fact the horses
were more important to the united states
than uniforms because we ensured that
our guard at that time had horses over
uniforms which came over 30 years later
and so the concept that this is somehow
new because it's a value add the reason
that horses are used in addition to
being able to traverse up to 50 miles a
day is that they can traverse terrain
that vehicles can't so when people say
oh just use atvs or why aren't we using
cars especially there in texas which the
president would know if he actually went
down to the border there's a particular
variety of cane that grows there that
makes it totally inaccessible to
anything but horseback it's also easy to
hide in which is why they're often in
between bushes and in that terrible
terrain looking for people exactly and
in terms of the rains you know keep in
mind guys that assaulting or hurting an
animal associated with law enforcement
that's a felony so why would we have it
protected as a felony and yet not enable
border patrol or law enforcement to use
techniques to have people stand back
from the animal that is an extension of
law enforcement that in the military we
also designate as officers it makes zero
sense and for these guys to simply
invoke slavery and these horrible uh
you know atrocious images um instead of
looking at the facts the history and the
value that it performs and now by the
way border patrol is using no horses
whatsoever dps texas dps is now
petroleum the border the state patrol is
now responsible for people just real
quickly when things actually do equal
the horrors of slavery we should call
them out and when they don't
maxine waters and anyone else who's
throwing it it's not that they weren't
bad images and and for the people
experiencing it horrifying and and you
can talk with them about it but it's not
like slavery and we cannot say that
things are like things that they're not
otherwise everything is slavery and it
has no meaning and we know that it does
and if something worse than slavery
happened according to maxine waters it
happened on biden's watch of notes so is
she saying this of the biden
administration she said she's kamala
harris heed at him i won't fill in the
word for her yeah absolutely but look
pete so regardless of what kamala says
and uh biden says we know that's not
true emily just took us through the
facts
but they're banning horses right that's
what the biden administration is doing
the daily caller had a very simple
question i'll pose it to you you can
give me the answer what's the best way
to stop illegal immigration a build a
wall b ban horses
because it's not about stopping illegal
immigration this is the shiny object the
distraction that they could find to
obsess about the question to joe biden
was not about horses and whipping which
has been completely debunked it's fake
news the question was about the disaster
at the border and because of these
images which the photographer even says
don't represent reality joe biden kamala
harris and maxine waters distract away
distract don't look don't look at
bidenville don't look under the bridge
in del rio texas don't look at the
disaster we created look at this one guy
on a horse using his reins around that's
been totally misconstrued and then for
max harris i'm so glad you said what you
said for maxine waters to say worse than
slavery what an insult to any slave or
descendant of a slave who was actually
whipped by a slave master that is that i
mean it is such egregious rhetoric
i don't even know how to respond to it
but they're they're using the horse
thing to distract because it's all a
disaster and they want more illegal
immigration they want it they do and a
lot of questions from my orcas and saki
when they take to the podium at 2 30
never forget my orcas began saying he
saw nothing inappropriate saki said she
was horrified and now all of a sudden
facts out the window we have my orcas
who's horrified where are the fact
checkers